today on the Matt Walsh show the country
as I'm sure you noticed is being ripped
to shreds at the moment dismantled by
people who claim that they are victims
of oppression and persecution but the
oppression and persecution are imaginary
they're claims of being oppressed and
persecuted are verifiably demonstrably
obviously false so why is this really
happening why is our society which is
freer and richer than any other other
society that has ever existed on earth
coming apart at the seams at the moment
I want to spend the show today analyzing
that question so that's what's coming up
today on the show and the format's gonna
be a little bit different actually I'm
abandoning the format completely just
for today because I want to spend a good
amount of time on this point fleshing it
out and we'll begin here congresswoman
Ilhan Omar made some notable remarks
during a press conference in Minnesota
yesterday she said that our economic and
political systems need to be quote
unquote dismantled listen as long as our
economy and political systems prioritize
profit without considering who is
profiting who is being shut out we will
perpetuate this inequality so we could
not stop at criminal justice system we
must begin the work of dismantling the
whole system of oppression wherever we
find it the whole system of oppression
must be dismantled she says and that
system is she says our economic and
political system so that's what she
wants to dismantle to be clear now you
listen to that and you really wonder
whether any non-western country would
ever tolerate the absurdity of an
immigrant coming to their country
obtaining political power and then
openly working towards the goal of
dismantling the very system that gave
them refuge in the first place and the
answer to that question is no no
non-western country would ever tolerate
that or allow it and neither should we
I think about Ilhan Omar's position okay
this country gave her everything she
came here for refuge received it and
then was quickly given power
prestige beyond the imagining of of most
natural-born citizens which you would
think would would mean that she would
live every day in gratitude for America
and what it gave to her but instead she
despises America and most of its
citizens I have never heard her express
uh Terr any gratitude at all I have
never heard her say thank you to America
for giving her everything
instead she comes here gets everything
and all she does every day is demand
more and that in itself wouldn't be so
bad I mean being greedy and selfish is
that's a lot of people are that that's
common but the worst part is that she
demands more while slandering this
country and its people and and you know
in this country that has already given
her more than most white people will
ever receive so it's the slander the
constant slander the constant lies the
desperate attempt to make America seem
like the nightmarish dystopia that she
apparently wishes it was systems of
oppression okay what oppression what are
you talking about what oppression
exactly and this is an important
question because omar along with
everyone else on the left and in the
media and and everyone out there looting
looting and rioting and protesting and
tearing down statues all of these people
are talking about this oppression this
persecution saying that they are
oppressed but none of them can explain
what exactly the oppression is or
provide evidence of it and that's
because it's imaginary they're inventing
it it isn't real they are not oppressed
to take this example just one one
example of a million there's an op-ed
just published by Teen Vogue okay
written by someone who goes by the
Twitter handle
Satan's Jacuzzi at Satan's jacuzzi as a
Twitter handle so you know this is gonna
be a thoughtful and persuasive argument
the op-ed argues that quote the United
States is by every indication more
committed to death subjugation and grief
than life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness that's that's quite a claim
the United States is committed to death
and subjugation I can think of some
countries that that off the top of my
head would really seem to fit that
description North Korea for example is
America as bad as North Korea really
well what proof is offered for that the
proof offered for this claim are the
murders of two black women wait which
happened recently completely unconnected
one was a woman killed while protesting
on a highway she was run over by a guy
in a car and another was a woman
murdered a few months ago a soldier who
was bludgeoned to death a very gruesome
and horrible the article takes these
cases and makes them into exhibit one in
exhibit one a which are supposed to show
that America is this oppressive hellhole
a a quote vast tapestry of death as the
article puts it and the Declaration of
Independence is a lie because black
people are being killed and and you know
the this is the argument being made what
the article doesn't mention anywhere is
that both women were killed by black men
why didn't the esteemed Satan's Jacuzzi
use an example of a white man killing a
black woman you could tell that that's
she would prefer an example like that
which is why she goes to great lengths
to avoid talking about the actual now
she tries vaguely to connect these
killings with racism but she never comes
out and says the race of the person who
committed the murder why is that because
it was a black man well why didn't she
just find an example a recent example of
a white man killing a black woman
wouldn't that be a lot better for her
point wouldn't wouldn't that illustrate
her point more well the reason she
didn't give us that example is because
it's extremely rare that white men kill
black women white on black violence in
in general is a rarity black on white
violence is in fact far more common here
are the FBI statistics from 2016 two
thousand eight hundred and seventy black
homicide victims two hundred and forty
three of the perpetrators were white two
thousand five hundred and seventy
were black now let's look at the white
victims 3499 murder victims were white
five hundred and thirty three of the
perpetrators are black most of the rest
were white and you see this is what
happens anytime you do a simple fact
check of these hysterical claims of
oppression that are being made the same
with the claims of police murdering
black people as I've shown as many
people have shown repeatedly there is no
evidence at all for any kind of epidemic
of racist police gunning down black
people we'll get into the to the actual
numbers there because I think that they
need to be we need to continually
highlight them in just a second but
before we do the show today's brought to
you by red power bikes look if you want
to get out and about get out of the
house get some get some fresh air
there's never been a better time to do
it especially now as it's getting warmer
and everything whether you want a way to
commute or to get around town or get
around the city just get out in it
whatever it is even if you have your
kids in tow you've got to try red power
bikes is a cross between a traditional
bike and a moped but it doesn't require
specials driver's license so you don't
have to worry about you know going
through any jump it through any hoops
for this you can go up to 20 miles per
hour without pedaling so you can go out
and about without getting all sweaty you
can go to work or something you don't
have to worry about work walking into
the office drenching you know drenched
in sweat which your co-workers might not
appreciate
unlike other ebikes they're actually
affordable plus to show appreciation for
those that serve us rad power bucks is
offering $100 off all ebike purchases
for active slash ex-military first
responders teachers and students
dedicated us-based customer support
seven days a week to answer any
questions or concerns and this is it's a
perfect gift as well to get someone and
and as I said it's it's affordable on
top of just being a heck of a lot of fun
rad power bikes offers flexible
financing for as low as 0% APR right now
is a limited time offer get a free
accessory with the purchase of a bike
that's right
get a free gift of up to a hundred
dollars in value and free shipping to
the lower 48 states to get this special
offer text the word
bike to 64,000 that's bike to 64,000
text bike to 64,000 okay what are just
to go over it again what are the actual
statistics on police killing people
according to a Washington Post database
and this is far from a far-right
organization that's trying to you know
get police off the hook
25 unarmed whites were killed by cops
last year 14 unarmed blacks were killed
the whole year across the whole country
and it would be totally irrational to
assume that all of those killings were
automatically unjustified just because
the person was unarmed remember that
Obama's DOJ found that the killing of
Michael Brown who was unarmed was
justified because he was rushing at and
trying to kill a cop so many of the
unarmed killings are like that you've
got a small small small minority of
police killings that are unarmed and a
small minority of those that are
questionable and that's it so the facts
don't support these claims of oppression
and yet you've got people marching
through the street with signs like this
you see these signs all over the place
stop killing us the signs say who are
you talking to who is killing you what
are you talking about the vast majority
of people of any race who are killed are
killed by other private citizens of that
same race so who are you talking to are
you protesting against murder in general
are you saying that all murder has to
stop an order for for you to no longer
be oppressed well that would be
ridiculous enough as it is because
murder will always happen in in human
society especially in a country 330
million people but it's even more
ridiculous than that because these
protesters with these signs aren't
talking about murder in general they're
talking about an imaginary epidemic of
white people and white cops going on
racist rampages and murdering black
people an article in the Atlantic also
makes this claim it says
right at the top and says I want white
people to stop killing us they're not
it's a very rare occurrence that is
extremely rare more black people are
killing white people than white people
are killing black people and in fact
considering that there are so many fewer
black people in the country the
statistical likelihood that a black
person kills a white person is
exponentially higher than the other way
around this again is the reality plain
as day
but the reality doesn't matter here's a
tweet from McDonald's McDonald's yes
that McDonald's the one that you know
sells Big Macs but they've been tweeting
far-left
you know BLM propaganda videos for the
last few weeks and here's one of them hi
Mario Jones the founder of transflash
media in this black lives matter moment
black trans women have a very simple
message stop killing us we can't expect
others to care about us more than we
care about ourselves we're all free or
Anonymous's stop killing us there it is
again but who are you talking to who is
killing you that there is no epidemic of
anti-trans murders it doesn't exist
yes trans people are murdered everyone
is murdered every group of people is
susceptible to being murdered because
we're all mortal and we live in a human
society where crime happens okay but you
know in terms of their bit of their
being an epidemic of trans people being
murdered by trans folks who are just out
killing trans people that almost never
happens that is extremely extremely rare
the vast majority of trans people who
are killed are killed by in domestic
violence or in drug-related or
prostitution related killings but let's
go back to the fact so you got the video
itself the claim being made in the video
which is which is absurd but the very
fact that this hysterical paranoia is
being
gated by McDonald's one of the largest
and richest corporations in America I
think that tells you something as well
and we'll talk about that in just a
second first I want to tell you about
our friends over at wise foods you know
it's it's extremely important and I
think this is a lesson we've all gotten
in recent months to be prepared in case
of emergency you know you don't like
thinking about the possibility of
emergency but we know that they happen
and so you want to be prepared our
sponsor wise company has changed their
name to ready wise now is a better time
than ever to be prepared with long-term
nutritional food options ready Wise has
many options like emergency meals freeze
dried fruits and vegetables for can be
convenient on the goat attrition they
also have adventure meals for hiking
camping other outdoor activities so you
know for ready wise it's not just about
getting prepared for emergency although
that's that's obviously important but
but if you like to go out like I do and
camp or go out in the woods you can grab
these meals which are delicious and and
and nutritious and you'll be good to go
get peace of mind during these uncertain
times knowing your family's prepared
with plenty of reliable nutritional
meals that have a very long shelf life
due to increase demand supplies are
limited and some items may currently be
out of stock so go there now ready wise
uses the finest ingredients the latest
food preparation technology so that and
I think that's an important aspect of
this so the food is actually good I can
attest to that this week my listeners
get free shipping at ready wise calm
when entering Walsh and check out a
checkout or by calling eight five five
four seven five three zero eight nine
ready Wise has a 90 day no questions
asked return policy so there's no risk
taking the initiative to get yourself
and your family prepared today but
remember supplies are limited go there
now ready wise dot-com ar e ad y-wis e
calm promo code Walsh to get free
shipping today okay so we've got
McDonald's tweeting these conspiracy
theories about about you know some sort
of imaginary epidemic of anti-trans hate
crimes in fact nearly all of the largest
and richest corporations in America
are spreading the utterly false talking
points of BLM Colin Kapernick has been
able to parlay his supposed at
oppression into multi-million dollar
deals with three major corporations
Disney Nike and Netflix Vanity Fair has
an article calling cap a burgeoning
media mogul this is oppression this is
what oppression looks like in America
you can turn your oppression into a into
a media franchise worth millions of
dollars then if that's the case I mean
God let me let me be oppressed please I
pray for that kind of oppression
meanwhile we've got leftist inventing
hate crimes fabricating them nearly
every week is another example people are
so desperate to be actually oppressed
that they're they're just making it up
as we talked about yesterday a bunch of
college students are now claiming that
they're that they're traumatized they
are so traumatized by a joke that some
kid tweeted about George Floyd that they
can't go back to school a tweet a tweet
is now is now latched on to desperately
as an example of oppression people are
so desperate for oppression that that to
white people who painted over a mural of
black lives matter which is just just on
the street there was really City
sanctioned graffiti with black lives
matter written across the street in big
bold letters well two white people came
and painted over it they're being
charged with a hate crime for doing that
for painting over letters so if we can't
find actual white racist oppressors out
there killing black people then let's
like let's make these two white people
painting over some words on the on the
street into our racist oppressors why
not or let's make a garage door pull
into a hate crime why not oh but the
black man who pummeled the white Macy's
employee that's not a hate crime or the
black man who knocked over a 92 year old
white woman
and she hit her head on a fire hydrant
that's not a hate crime
or the black men who beat a white woman
with two by fours in New York that's not
a hate crime
yes but the white folks with paint who
painted over letters on the streets
committed a hate crime oh but the
Vandals who are literally burning
buildings and tearing down priceless
works of art those aren't hate crimes
either but this is you see that's how it
works the whole thing is a farce this
oppression is imaginary hallucinatory
it's not real it's not happening there
is no crisis towns and states across the
country are declaring racism a public
health crisis it's not the only crisis
is the one that left is protestors and
the media and Democrats are inventing
creating we are right now witnessing
something that is that is probably
unprecedented in the history of the
world a bunch of people who live lives
of freedom and liberty and and and
relative comfort and luxury are choosing
to destroy their country because they've
convinced themselves that they're the
victims of a completely imaginary
oppression it's as though our society
got bored with with with its own success
and decided to eat itself for fun here's
the reality unless you live in the inner
city of Chicago or a city like that you
are safer richer more comfortable more
secure and freer than almost everyone
who has ever lived anywhere at any point
anywhere in the world you are in the top
top top 1% if not if not even if not in
even more exclusive company than that
and in fact even in the inner city you
are wealthy compared to a great portion
of the world's population you may not be
very safe but the danger you face is
almost entirely from within
own community from criminals and drug
dealers and murderers within your
community it's not from racist agents of
the state going around randomly killing
people because they're not doing that
but of course it's doubtful that that
most of the protesters and people
tearing down statues and everything
actually live in the inner city many of
them are relatively affluent living
lives of to most people in the world
unimaginable ease and comfort in fact
lives that are so easy and comfortable
that they can somehow afford to spend
days on end protesting and they still
have food to eat and a roof over their
head to come home to the students at
k-state who are traumatized over over
the tweet actually had the time and
energy and luxury to protest over it
watch this
they're marching through the streets oh
for a tweet that they didn't like
imagine having that kind of luxury
one student mentioned in the Kansas City
comm article Michela Ross has an
internship at Exxon Mobil okay and and
but she had trouble at her internship
because she was so traumatized by the
tweet Exxon Mobil one of the most again
one of the most powerful corporations on
earth she has an internship there she
goes to a major American University and
thus just based on those two things
she's in a better position and lined up
for more financial and professional
success than literally billions of other
people on earth and yet she says she's
oppressed because of a tweet it makes
her scared she lives in fear now because
of the tweet so how is this all
happening why are a bunch of spoiled
brats who have been given everything and
who have never been oppressed in their
lives nonetheless trying to burn the
country to the ground why are they go
screaming about imaginary monsters why
are we watching our society
self-destruct at a moment in history
when it has achieved unprecedented
wealth luxury and liberty well we could
spend you know twelve hours or so
dissecting this I'm not gonna spend 12
hours but I do want to dissect it and
try to answer that question and we will
do that in just a second but first I
want to tell you about our new sponsors
we talked about yesterday blink sale
blink sale if the revolutionary
invoicing software that's changing the
landscape for small businesses and
independent contractors everywhere you
know you don't want to waste time trying
to make invoices I've done this myself
even though I'm not a small business
owner but even if you're not you know
you might have occasions to make
invoices and it's just you end up with
these clunky ugly things and it's it's
it's not worth the time many business
owners know there are so many moving
parts it can be hard to manage
everything and still stay on track doing
what you love that's why you got to
start streamlining things and finding
ways to help yourself
a big part of that is invoicing and if
you've hassled a client that owed you
money or you've gotten lost trying to
keep track of your invoices and payments
maybe you have just a basic template on
Microsoft Word or whatever it is it's
just it's a big hassle that's why our
friends over a blink sale built an
invoicing software that helps you stay
on top of your money and keep track of
everything in one place so you could
stop sending those nagging emails to get
paid phew to work with blink sale you
can send beautiful custom branded
invoices and estimates in seconds you
can stay on top of your outstanding
invoices you can let your customers and
clients easily pay your invoices online
there's just you can do whatever you
want and as an added bonus blink sales
giving away ten dollars to five hundred
daily wire fans here's how to get it go
to blink sale comms start your 14-day
free trial
create your first invoice of ten dollars
and activate an online payment option
then you can send the invoice to daily
wire at blink sale comm and you get paid
your 10 dollars the first 500 people to
send an invoice for 10 dollars to Delhi
wired at blink sale comm will get their
invoice paid by blink sale limit of one
per person stop wasting time invoicing
and try blink sale for free at blink
sale dot-com / walls that's bli and
si le dot-com / Walsh blink sale spend
less time billing and more time doing
what you love okay so why is this all
happening
Dostoevsky in the in The Brothers
Karamazov defines the modern conception
of freedom as the rapid multiplication
and satisfaction of desire and he says
that that's the way modern man sees
freedom which means that if there's any
desire that is not immediately fulfilled
then you're oppressed to be oppressed is
to have your freedom taken away and if
freedom is the satisfaction of desire
and you have any desire at all that's
not satisfied then you're oppressed if
there's a if there's the slightest bump
in the road like say a tweet you don't
like now you're oppressed you're
victimized you're persecuted and I think
that explains a lot of what we're seeing
is our is our misunderstanding of what
freedom and liberty actually is but I
also think there's something else it's
it seems that we are what we're
discovering is that struggle is a basic
human need humans need to have something
to struggle against humans need to
suffer even in small small doses
suffering is an actual need that we have
what we can't do is just sit in our
luxury just sit there and enjoy it and
be unendingly happy and satisfied we
can't look at all the rich and famous
people who are extremely miserable even
to the point of committing suicide that
perfectly illustrates the point here
they have everything a person could ever
want but they're in total despair now
most of us are not rich in comparison to
these celebrities but we are as I said
rich in comparison to most people who
have ever lived on earth and we're
having the same problem we're running
into the same issue we cannot simply
luxurious in our comforts we cannot be
happy that way decadence is not quite as
fun or
filling as we thought it would be so we
need a struggle we need some kind of
struggle even as we sit in our homes in
our air conditioning with refrigerator
stocked with food and we and we sit on
our couches and we're comfortable we
watch TV or Netflix all day what are we
watching the stories that we watch the
stories that that that that we like to
have told to us through whatever medium
are all stories of people struggling
fighting overcoming those are those have
always been since time immemorial ever
since human beings have been telling
stories to each other those are always
the stories that we tell and because we
find something appealing about that and
I think we long to overcome something
ourselves to have our own fight our own
struggle we can't be happy just
witnessing the re-enacted struggles of
other people we need to have our own now
there are basically two ways to go about
this to make your struggle for yourself
there's the healthy way the way that
will lead to actual fulfillment and a
measure of happiness and the unhealthy
way the way that will lead to
destruction and despair and everything
we're seeing right now
now the healthy way the healthy creation
of struggle is to set out to do things
that are difficult things that are not
strictly speaking necessary you don't
have to do them but you do them anyway
you embrace the sacrifice because the
struggle is worth what you gain from it
the most obvious and and I think
important example of this is starting a
family there's a lot of sacrifice that
that comes with starting a family a lot
of pain a lot of a lot of struggle that
comes with it there's also love and
there's purpose and there is meaning you
know and there are many other benefits
as well so by starting a family you've
made a struggle you've taken on a fight
but it's a good one it's a worthy one
you know but but but you have you you
you've gone from you know you're single
living alone or for most people living
with your parents
your life is very easy and uncomplicated
and then you decide to start a family
and you have just willfully taken on all
of these additional complications and
there are so many things and many that
you don't even know ahead of time but
you'll realize there's so many things
that were that were easy before you had
a family and now and now they're and now
they're a struggle but it's worth it
it's a worthy struggle and then there
are much less they're much smaller
examples of less significant struggles
and sacrifices that you might choose to
make some people like to work out like
to exercise there's a struggle there's a
sacrifice you don't need to do it right
it's good for you
you'll probably live longer if you do
but you don't need to do it you could
you could just sit out sit on your ass
all day if you want through a lot of
people do but you do it anyway in my
family we garden we raise chickens we
have bees right we don't need to do any
of this it's certainly a harder way to
get your vegetables and eggs and honey
but we do it the hard way on purpose
because we enjoy it you know and there
in fact I was just recently thinking
that because I like to fish I usually do
catch and release but I was thinking
that you know I'm gonna start once a
week actually bringing the fish home and
you know making a meal from what I catch
now going out and catching a fish and
cleaning and gutting and cooking it that
is a very hard way to do something that
you could do in 35 minutes if you just
pulled some salmon or whatever out of
your fridge and throw it into the oven
but I like the idea of doing it the hard
way of providing a meal for my family
actually providing and not just buying
it but providing it and of course there
are people who hunt or do other things
there are men who are really handy
around the house I'm not I'm ashamed to
say but if there's a problem with the
plumbing or some other issue you know
they could easily call someone that fix
it but they're gonna fix it themselves
why well it saves money maybe but that's
not the main reason I think the main
reason is to do it the hard way just for
the sake of doing it that's it doing it
for the sake of it there was a time of
course
when the majority of early the majority
of human history in fact when people had
no choice but to do everything the hard
way if you wanted something built you
had to build it if you wanted something
to eat you had to grow it or catch it or
kill it and you noticed that in those
times you rarely had people marching
through the streets over imaginary
oppression now they might have marched
over real oppression but even then most
of the time it took quite a bit of it
for them to actually mobilize in anyway
and and and then when they did mobilize
they mobilized in a serious way but
these people had their struggle every
day was a struggle they didn't need to
create struggles for themselves because
every other human need was not
automatically met the human need for
struggle was met now that's the way it
was for them and since it's not that way
for us
we have to come up with our own
struggles we've talked about the healthy
way of doing it what about the unhealthy
way to create struggle before we even
get to the protesters you know we all
know people who create unhealthy
struggles for themselves all the time
think about the people who are
constantly inventing drama and strife in
their relationships they could be
perfectly happy in a relationship
everything seems to be fine and then one
day they seem to almost just randomly
destroy it for no reason they have
convinced them sorry but but of course
it's never their fault right they've
convinced themselves that everyone is
out to get them all of their
relationships fall apart whether
romantic relationships or familial
relationships whatever it is
relationships at work friendships all
the relationships are always falling
apart they're always having problems
with ever but with everybody but and
from the outside you can see that it's
almost always their fault because these
are extremely difficult and selfish
self-centered people but in their minds
from their telling their victims they
just have enormous ly bad luck and
everybody they meet is it ends up being
a terrible person and betrays them and
back stabs them and everything else
these are people who are inventing a
struggle they live on drama
and gossip and resentment and feelings
of personal injury that's that's they
thrive on it because they are fulfilling
that need for struggle that way
I think the protesters are in this camp
they are doing a version of this same
thing they are creating their struggle
these are people who have either
outright rejected the healthy forms of
struggle or or who have found those
forms unfulfilled because they're too
selfish and weak to find fulfillment in
the sacrifice they require because I'm
not there are plenty of people as I just
mentioned who start a family which is
the healthy form of struggle but then
end up as we just discussed
relationships fall apart and everything
else because you can't be entirely
self-centered you have to be willing to
accept the sacrifice so these are people
who have found those forms of struggle
unfulfilled because they're too selfish
or they've rejected it outright and I I
suspect that the majority are in the
latter camp these are largely people who
don't have families of their own who
don't oh don't do anything for
themselves who've had everything handed
to them many times don't even have jobs
everything is done for them they live
enormously easy lives and now they're
trying to fashion themselves into
freedom fighters except they already
have freedom so instead they're fighting
dragons and boogie men of their own
imagination and if they succeed in
taking down the country in dismantling
it as Ilhan omar says she wants to do
they will have dismantled it in order to
stop an oppression that they invented
that was only ever in their nightmares
in their or maybe in their dreams I
should say because it's very obvious
that they want to be oppressed and then
the great irony here the very morbid
irony is that if they succeed in in
tearing down the country and destroying
it you know whatever it replaces it
whatever replaces the old system that we
had the system that created all of this
this great luxury and wealth and freedom
for everybody
if they get rid of that then then then
they will finally have I think the
suffering and oppression that they
wanted but once they really have it I
don't think they're gonna want it
anymore
so I think we'll leave it there as I
said got away from the normal format of
the show today so we don't have the the
headlines and cancellation everything I
think I've sort of lumped it all in
together it's all mixed in there but
we'll get back to all that tomorrow
thanks for listening everybody thanks
for watching Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producers are Mathis
Glover and Robert Sterling our technical
producer is Austin Stevens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 Ilan Omar calls for
dismantling the American economy and
political systems DeSean Jackson
endorses and then disavow his Hitler
because he's a bad person gotta give him
credit for that and liberal squishes
can't pick a side check it out on the
Michael Nolt show
[Music]